hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
uh september
5th
2022
what's going on how are ya
how you doing i hope you're doing all
right i'm not doing all right i'm in a
[ __ ] depressed mood
i really am i just you know
did you know what i think the way you
stay out of depression is you just give
up hope and then you just sit back and
you just gotta [ __ ] laugh at the
whole thing
but you can't cause there's like kids
involved
you know
bill what are you talking about you know
what i'm talking about i'm talking about
the fact it's been over 100 degrees out
it's going to be that way for like five
straight days out here
and like
if you read up on this [ __ ] since the
late 1950s scientists were warning
corporations
and politicians that these days were
coming they did [ __ ] nothing about it
they just kept taking the paychecks from
the evil [ __ ]
they started making [ __ ] uh what is this
stuff where you design it to break
design obsolescence whatever the [ __ ]
that they did
so you just had to keep throwing your
[ __ ] out they put repairman out of
business you just had to keep buying the
new thing we just kept throwing the [ __ ]
in the ocean
and now here we are
here we are right
and then what are these [ __ ] news
corporations gonna do
who allegedly love this country and
allegedly trying to steer us into a
bluer or redder future whatever the [ __ ]
their politics are what are they doing
nothing all they're gonna do is just do
what they do to make money is scare the
herd now you're gonna see a bunch of
[ __ ] articles about water and the
scarcity of water and all of that and
they're just gonna pit us against each
other as they're up there banging
hookers eating crap
i give up
i [ __ ] give up it was it was easier
to give up when you could just go
outside
but uh
like the level of [ __ ]
i mean i went outside this morning to
shut off the lights you know
i guess i shouldn't leave those on huh
it's a waste of [ __ ] right maybe i
should get a gun
instead of leave the lights on that's
probably better for that's better for
global warming don't leave your lights
on all night let the burglar come in
kill the burglar now you just ended
somebody's car carbon footprint there we
go look at that look at that
two minutes 39 seconds in we came up
with the solution where i can make my
little corner of the earth a little
better
um anyway
uh and i know they're they're out here
they're telling people to lose use less
water
and i know good and goddamn well all the
richy rich people out here like that
doesn't apply to us
and they're [ __ ] doing whatever the
[ __ ] they it is that they want to do
having a water orgy
that'll be the new way to display wealth
you know
in hip-hop videos in the future
rappers will be dumping fiji water on
some strippers ass
you know that'll be the new crystal
um oh well well you know what you can
only die once
here's one would you rather [ __ ] dry
out like this or freeze to death
i don't know
anyway
speaking of [ __ ] disasters and i've
been staying away from this one
you know cause my team sucks this year
but it's i got to address it at this
point
the new york yankees are in the midst
of one of the most historic regular
season
if not the most historic
collapse
that i've ever seen and i'm a [ __ ]
red sox fan i'm not one of these new new
ones
that they they know a couple of [ __ ]
world series every decade right i'm part
of the old school
like i'm trying to think in 1978 we had
a sizable lead was not [ __ ] 17 games
they had a 17 game that's that's the
kind of lead you have on a last place
tape
i'll tell you how bad we suck as much as
this [ __ ] in the bed we're still 13 and
a half games back
um at 66 and 68.
i mean if you told me in september that
the red sox would only have 66 wins i
would say we would be at least 30 games
back
on the yankees instead we're 38
13 and a half
the tampa bay devil race
as of saturday night won the first two
of i believe a three or four game series
um they win today on sunday they're
gonna be three games back and we have a
whole month left
tampa is on a tear they won
eight of their last ten
at least on this thing i don't know what
their deal is eight of the eight and two
their last ten
yankees four and six
baltimore seven and three
toronto and boston six and four [ __ ]
unbelievable
cleveland the guardians the security
company their [ __ ] in the bed
the twins are only a game back
white sox are two games back al central
wide open
um
and now all of a sudden out of nowhere
running away with the best record
in the american league who would have
thought it the houston astros
no trash cans didn't go to home depot
just doing it with good old-fashioned
iphones they're
they're 85 and 48.
the seattle almost called them the
seahawks the seattle mariners 75 in 58
i mean
this is it's [ __ ] bananas
new york mets best record
in new york city baseball who would have
thought 85 and 49
but there are only two games up against
the defending world series champions the
atlanta braves don't count them out and
then the saint louis
cardinals who arguably have an mvp
themselves at first base whatever his
[ __ ] name is i was looking up his
stats hitting like 3 30.
it's got 32 home runs
and you're like oh aaron judge has 51.
all right well he only has five more
rbis than that guy you still got to give
it to aaron judge and then the best
record in baseball at 91 and 49.
running away with the division is the
los angeles dodgers
um
i mean what the [ __ ] happened i thought
i was like
i was like you know when the yankees go
play the angels i got to go see them
this is you get this is like seeing the
98 yankees you got to go too much as you
hate them you got to go see it this will
be one of the great [ __ ] teams of all
time they are now
594 winning percentage they dropped like
a hundred [ __ ] points
percentage points
since july
and i went to the all-star game
the buddy of mine who's a yankee fan and
he was standing tall wearing that yankee
hat
um
red sox are actually been kind of fun to
watch uh right now because they just
they're bringing up uh
just bringing up some young talent
seeing what they do some kid from
worcester came up and hit a [ __ ]
monster
over the monster over the screen no
souvenir for you
probably hit the parking attendant
across the street hit an absolute bomb
and then i saw this other kid young kid
like 23 years old
came out and he pitched like six solid
innings like a week ago or something
like that
i don't know
i'm never getting out of that edit room
i don't think it's ever gonna end
i was all excited
you know we're gonna lock on this day in
september i'm like great i'm like
fantastic and then it's behind me
all right i did fenway that's behind me
now the movie's behind me they're like
nope then we do the color and the sound
i now know why directors have those
[ __ ] zz top beards
[Music]
you know they just [ __ ] get in there
and i don't think they have time it has
to be
after a while you just get it down
it has to be
i would think so but my my level of
respect for uh directors editors
producers and all of that type of [ __ ]
this has been a very very
great thing for me to do i am towards
the end
but uh you know i i really envisioned
myself by mid-september having that old
school football fan hat you know the
hard hat with the two cups of beer and
the straw
and went right to your mouth
um
which was a funny idea
it was always a funny idea nobody really
did it
you're not going to sit there like what
are you like a [ __ ] pacifier
there there are certain things
especially back then
especially back then that you just
certain things you could not do you
could not drink a beer
beer with a straw
i was just thinking if there was like a
reality show
where it was like
whoever gets their ass kicked in a bar
first you know gets to the next round
a good move
would be to to go into a a
you know a bar that's known to have a
bunch of uh tough customers as they used
to say
and go in there and get a beer with and
start drinking it with the straw
and then just looking
at a few guys a little bit too long
[Laughter]
if you survived you would advance to the
next round
um
anyway uh i watched some football
yesterday
um i watched all of the uh i just sat
and watched the whole thing
i watched the georgia bulldogs reverse
them versus them oregon ducks and i'll
tell you right now then them dogs had
ducks for [ __ ] dinner man
i mean it wasn't even a game
it wasn't even a game just from the
beginning to the end i didn't see the
bands at halftime but i'm guessing
georgia [ __ ] played a better flute
than they did in [ __ ] oregon it was
just a wire to wire
trashing i mean it was like we it was
like a third of the third quarter was
left
and they were already talking about how
the quarterback from oregon is a gamer
and he's gonna learn something from this
it was one of those games
you know there's there's a lot of pride
in this oregon's oregon duck uh uh team
out here you know
you know they go and i'll tell you right
now you know they got they got they got
a less steckle over here and uh harry
miles
yeah they're great uh
coaches
and uh you know they're gonna build
these kids up they're gonna know what to
do
they're they're gonna they're gonna
watch the game film and then uh if i
know and if i know les decker miles he's
gonna put this behind him
and i'll tell you right now i would not
i would not want to be the team that is
playing the oregon ducks next week
they were doing that in the third
quarter
you know they have some pretty green
uniforms
uh i mean uh you know there's a lot of
positives to take from this who else who
else would think to put those feathers
on the side
like wings
to to insinuate and remind folks at home
that they they are in fact the ducks
i mean if i'm emilio estevez right now
i'm thinking why did i make the mighty
ducks about a hockey team when i should
have made it about these oregon ducks in
the third quarter
in the third some of the best
concessions i've ever eaten it was
actually in georgia so i can't say that
um
and uh yeah georgia
bulldog fans i mean jesus christ if you
bet that game
and you bet the dogs you i mean it's
just one of those few games you could
just put your [ __ ] feet up
i guess the quarterback at oregon was at
auburn and then he transferred
um that's like a big thing now
transferring way more
than it used to be
um
kids just switching around and [ __ ] and
now money's gonna get involved
and all of that it's just going to be
you know
another thing for global warming let's
make super conferences in football
[Laughter]
let's have another
60 teams of [ __ ] team planes flying
around that's gonna be like another
selling point
at that you know when they start paying
them is going to be like well what kind
of team plane do you have
um
but anyway uh i just got a text message
i have no idea what this means
you get to the hotel
no no sorry that was an old one
say you get to the hotel tomorrow at 3
30 it's like i'm not in a [ __ ] hotel
tomorrow i'm home
enjoying
a little bit of labor day and then i
watched uh the first
half which was a great half of football
of notre dame versus ohio state
uh which kind of went the direction i
thought it was but i did not think that
um
that notre dame was going to look that
good against ohio state and ohio state
looked great
um
i liked uh
i liked it they had there was actually
some balls
in the notre dame team they were [ __ ]
putting their hats on people as much as
you can without getting called for a
[ __ ] uh
what do you call it uh targeting or
something like that but um
and then ohio state very impressive
weathered the storm as they said they
weathered the storm and then they were
they were 21 10 but there was a moment
there was like seven or three i'm
looking look at the [ __ ] notre dame
i thought maybe they get like a field
goal and then ohio state was going to do
the old right there fred
what does what does
what does and next thing you know it's
like 28 3 at the half
you know and everybody's running around
after every [ __ ]
you know
what the [ __ ] university of miami
started with that turnover chain is just
uh
it's just really gotten out of control
like i don't even i don't even
understand
what it is my buddy sent me one like if
they get a turnover they the guy goes
over and he play plays the slots
which i'm surprised the ncaa allows that
you're encouraging gambling
which we
want to get in business with but want
you to stay away from
[Laughter]
like honestly how long before the
draftkings and all of those guys
they'll get down to that level
um by the way my wife watched a couple
of uh [ __ ] um documentaries this week
and i've just been so [ __ ] wiped out
i kind of fell asleep during them
and uh
she watched that one i think i brought
it up on the last podcast she was
watching the one
of that kid at notre dame that got
fished
i mean that whole [ __ ] wild scenario
and then it was funny because the person
that was doing it was actually a dude
who then transitioned
so then they couldn't really
give that person [ __ ]
without looking like
transphobic or something
it's just like there's a lot of people
that transitioned they never did that
[Music]
just because your transitions doesn't
mean you can't also be an [ __ ] i mean
that's how it works
there's [ __ ] everywhere and i just
thought that they could have gone a
little [ __ ] harder
and been like hey [ __ ] just because
you were
dealing with this this but but doesn't
it then reflect on society that this
person wasn't allowed to be who they
wanted to be
i think they go that way
i don't know
i guess we're all [ __ ] at the end of
the day isn't that what it is oh jeep
bill that was so [ __ ] deep it took
you 17 minutes to come to that
conclusion
um
anyway uh
i don't even tell you about like i don't
even know i'm like [ __ ] like just
sitting here in air conditioning
thinking like i'm just adding to it just
being more hot outside
how do you think this ends
you've seen that [ __ ] where they have
all that they have like
all this underground thing underground
with
that the uh the government has
like these underground like [ __ ]
super bunkers with enough food for like
30 years
i think that that's their uh
i think that that's their game plan
it's just self-preservation because then
what's gonna happen is you're gonna be
down there but this is the thing though
that's a good sci-fi movie is then they
get down there right and they
survive and then everybody dies up top
right and then they're down there what
are they going to do after a while
huh
they're going to [ __ ] they're going
to be banging each other right which
means they're going to be making
kids and then they're only going to have
a certain
supply
of uh
of food
because everything above ground is going
to be too goddamn hot and dead
right it's all burned up you can't do
anything right you just got to stay on
and they and then their
survival is they they're going to have
to live underground
and eventually
you
know oh my god they're gonna start
eating each other
and then how does that work did the
young eat the old
the olds keep making younger ones so
they got something to eat
how does it work
you know what i mean what are the rules
is every race invited
like you know
what part of the menu does does a white
baby go on versus
[Laughter]
uh or we could try to [ __ ] why can't we
work together i don't know it's like
though it's like [ __ ] real housewives
i don't understand
why everybody can't just be like all
right let's just step back take a
[ __ ] break
you know why cuz because of um
you know why because god makes
sociopaths that's why and god makes
slackjawed mouth-breathing [ __ ]
morons
that just prevents it
from working that's basically
that's basically what it is so i would
think
here's the one what if they just somehow
they came up with a test and they just
figured out how to get rid of anybody
who isn't empathetic
you know
i'd say anybody who wasn't racist or
homophobic but everybody has degrees of
that
like there's no [ __ ] i don't care how
open-minded you are there's a social
situation
that that that you can get put in where
you're gonna be like i have to get the
[ __ ] out of here i'm not comfortable
so um
i guess i'm saying there's no solution
but it is football season
um
anyway
i've been uh i've been having a great
week back here as far as like hanging
out with the kids despite the fact it's
been so freaking hot dude it was so hot
i had to literally uh
you know which also adds to global
warming is i am
you know
flown a helicopter and [ __ ] forever
and i was gonna forget how to do it
i had to do it like [ __ ] eight in the
morning
and i'm up there like and i'm spraying
low-lead fuel into the atmosphere so
what am i doing
oh man
we we've gotten ourselves this this part
this is too deep this is too deep for me
all right
it's just [ __ ] too much man
um i have been seeing things on this
saying that global warming is a lie this
planet can sustain 18 billion people
it's just like is that right
and just exactly what does that look
like
i mean that swirl of trash
that we've achieved
i'm gonna look at it positively that we
achieved
all the [ __ ] that we've thrown out from
all the [ __ ] that we bought that we
didn't need or it was designed to break
so we'd have to buy another one is now
like two miles deep and like one and a
half times the size of texas the last
time i had the balls to even look at it
uh that's what seven billion people did
so you wanna go you wanna double that
plus
you you want to go one and a half more
i don't know
i don't know about that that's why you
know you you would have thought mother
nature would have come a little harder
with covid
you know we're still out [ __ ]
whatever she can come with
you know
it's kind of like that ohio state game
for as much as notre dame showed up and
played their a game they weathered the
storm and then they just kept [ __ ]
going
they put a couple of dents in the side
of their refrigerator but they they they
they didn't they didn't tip it over
is that a new sports analogy bill
is that the food network
meets the [ __ ] uh sec channel
um
anyway i'm i gotta take i gotta pause
here because i'm still waiting for uh
my advertising
my adverts for the week let me see if
these things showed up here
let me see let me
let's see here
[Music]
why does it take me so long to get to
what the [ __ ] that i need
i don't know what the [ __ ] i downloaded
but now every time i go to click on
something like four other new windows
pop up
like hey you want to watch this video on
youtube
it doesn't say hey but like that's the
vibe i get from it
it's [ __ ] annoying so all right i
guess i don't have anything there well
there goes that
there goes that discussion
um by the way
uh
nfl football starts this
thursday night with the buffalo bills
versus the defending
super bowl champions
the los angeles rams who by the way i'm
hearing the reason why they keep signing
all of these people is because they
figured out a way around the cap that if
you pay him cash
is that true
it can't be true that can't be what
they're doing because i know
i mean if the patriots did that we'd
never hear the end of it
let's see here rams
pay
cash
rent paid cash paid ram cash she allowed
discount uh
salary cap let's see if this comes up
was it just a hate and
the cash over cap philosophy is well
explained by andrew brandt on the pat
mcafee show
in the clip below he explains how the
ram were able to pay stafford 61.5
million this season with a calip
salary cap hit of just 13.5 million what
the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
where
is
cash game on espn why aren't they
tearing their [ __ ] hairs out about
that and then and questioning whether
that's a real [ __ ] championship you
[ __ ] answer me that
okay i i want to get to the bottom what
in the [ __ ] did the new england patriots
do to roger goodell i want to know what
the [ __ ] we did
that they're literally weighing our
footballs and this [ __ ] [ __ ]
13 and a half they [ __ ] buried like
almost 48 million dollars
why the titans can't play the salary cap
game the rams are
wow so much for [ __ ] parody oh what a
surprise another la team buys a [ __ ]
championship
all right
why do i care why do i care
all right
i shouldn't care
i should not care
oh my god i am gonna have so much
[ __ ] fun
watching this video
learning about this [ __ ] and then going
on a goddamn sports [ __ ] podcast to
[ __ ] i can't wait for the next time
somebody brings up that [ __ ] gym er
say horseshit
that is unbelievable we'll give you 61
and a half billion dollars and it's only
going to be 13 and a half on the [ __ ]
cap
isn't
that
something shout out to the pat mcafee
show
huh
i don't know why that man isn't isn't
standing there instead of being in a
tank top he should be dressing like a
gum shoe
he'd probably look like a flash or
pervert in the park but you know
whatever i'm just saying
good for him
the cash over philosophy is that's a
philosophy
oh is that what it is
it's oh i that's though that's why
that's why it is i'm sorry
that's a philosophy
everybody else
everybody else is uh gamesmanship
philosophy
a little uh you know little
tongue-in-cheek thing we're being a
little cheeky
[ __ ] unbelievable [ __ ] the [ __ ]
rams
[ __ ] the ramps
explaining how the rams can afford so
many big contracts here we go
here we go
this is a question many fans are asking
after seeing the rams pay yet another
star it's valid question two considering
the nfl has a salary cap that each team
has to stay under
um unless they have a philosophy that
gets around it this offseason alone the
rams paid matthew stafford alan robinson
bobby wagner aaron donald and cooper cup
the total value of those contracts is
431 and a half million a massive amount
of money allocated to just five players
and when it comes to guaranteed money
the sum is north of 310 million that is
total guarantees not guaranteed at
signing
so there must be incentives so again how
do the rams keep affording all these
contracts the short answer is is that
they're really good at maneuvering this
oh is that what they are are they really
good at maneuvering
oh my god these [ __ ] adjectives are
gonna kill me
yeah they're not cheating
they're not getting an unfair advantage
they're not doing some boss hog [ __ ]
they're just really good at maneuvering
the salary cap and figuring out ways to
move money around so that they don't
strap themselves financially in a single
year
it's not as if the rams are paying 431.5
million to those five players this year
alone they have plenty of time to pay
that money out thanks to the structure
of those contracts dude [ __ ] this [ __ ]
[ __ ] this [ __ ] okay looks good for them
that they figured that out all right but
i want all of you [ __ ]
all the you [ __ ] that came after my
patriots i want you to have the same
froth
coming out of the sides of your [ __ ]
mouths with the goddamn rams as you did
with the patriots where is that where's
jim irsay now
huh
what's he buying princess [ __ ] ring on
[ __ ] ebay what is he doing now he
doesn't give a [ __ ] about the rims that
guy was so that that [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ]
oh
one of the biggest [ __ ] cheats
manipulating massaging
philosophically maneuvering the [ __ ]
system ever and espn jumped on that
[ __ ] jumped on that that [ __ ] amp
ambulance chaser and rode that right
into the sunset of [ __ ] ratings of
fans of loser football teams
i mean that was a [ __ ] goddamn
year-long [ __ ] story over a [ __ ] hair
what the air taken out of a [ __ ] ball
that they found the colts had done the
same to their their footballs
that lasted a [ __ ] year
these guys are completely manipulating
the salary cap building a supers team
and going around league parody
and nobody has a [ __ ] thing to say
about it and they're actually
complimenting them
the short answer is they're really good
at it
[Laughter]
way to go rams
wait wait to figure out a way to give
yourself a ridiculously unfair advantage
and win a super bowl trophy
and congratulations to espn
sitting on your [ __ ] hands on this
one
you know what it is
sam donaldson is that his [ __ ] name
whatever his [ __ ] name is their
quarterback he's just was it did it
really just come down to the fact that
tom brady was beautiful
you know i don't know
i don't know matthew stafford sam
donaldson that's a [ __ ] news anchor
that's how mad i am
matthew sam donaldson
sorry it's been hot the last few days
out here
oh god here come the photoshop sam
donaldson trending
on the rams website
matthew stafford yeah he's just a
regular looking guy he looks like he
wrote one country hit single
he had a good year
in the late 90s or maybe the beginning
of george bush's uh
campaign in 2000 when he went went up
against [ __ ] al gore my turn
that [ __ ] guy
the guy who told us about the
inconvenient truth
um as he flew around the private jet
like how did he not see that coming the
way i should have seen i can't sit there
and rant rave about this when i flew a
[ __ ] helicopter for no reason other
than i just want to remember how to do
it yesterday
um
i flew great by the way
[Music]
um
yeah
i flew [ __ ] great and uh
it was a nice
nice time out there nice solitude made
me not think about anything
other than you know what i had to do up
there
it's a good time
i like flying out uh
going up to five new hall pass and just
going out there it's a lot quieter
up by six flags
bang a left go to
santa ines
you
know
that's always a fun one
hey any pilots out there flying to santa
enas where is the junkyard
i always hear over the junkyard i know
it's west of the airport but i've google
mapped it i cannot find the junkyard did
there used to be a junkyard there and
now it's something else so it's still
just called the junkyard
the same way they say uh old mako
for burbank even though whatever the
[ __ ] that was doesn't exist anymore
um all right i am still waiting for my
reads man i'm still waiting for the
reeds man
oh by the way this week uh
i got a run of dates coming up
and i'm also gonna see i'm gonna go
revisit my ute
in um
where the f oh here we go we got some
live reads here beautiful
i'm gonna go see the uh i'm gonna go see
joan jett
or as my daughter calls her joan jett
rocks
because i used to say that to her
and she'd be like dad who's this and i
would say joan jett
and she'd be like joan jett i go yeah
joan jet rocks
so then she started saying dad can you
put on can you put on joan jet rocks
all right uh butcher box everybody you
know finding quality food isn't always
easy processed food and poor production
practices are running rampant
why is it running rampant why don't the
politic oh that's right because they're
paid by those pricks
uh luckily there's butcher box butcher
box takes the guesswork out of finding
high quality meat and seafood you can
trust 100 grass-fed beef free-range
organic chicken pork raised crate free
and wild caught seafood humanely raised
no antibiotics or added hormones
ultimate convenience
get just what you want delivered right
to your doorstep free shipping
for the continental u.s and no surprise
fees choose from a variety of box plan
options from curated to customize and
change your plan whenever you want take
chicken breasts off your grocery list
butcher boxes offering our listeners an
incredible deal that they've never
offered before free chicken for a year
free get two pounds of free-range
organic chicken breasts for every for
free in every order when you sign up at
butcherbox.com and use the code burr
claim this deal at butcherbox.com and
use the code burr here's a question
is there anything more precious than the
safety of you and your loved ones of
course not so isn't
so isn't it strange
that not all home security uh companies
truly put you first old school home
security companies set you up with
outdated technology overcharge you for
service and lock you into
uh binding multi-year contracts
that's why i use and trust simply save
home security simply save protects you
with cutting edge security technology
powered by 24 7 professional monitoring
agents who always have your back with 24
7 professional monitoring simply safes
agents call you
the moment a threat is detected and
dispatch police or first responders in
an emergency even if you're not at home
or can't be reached simply safe
blankets your home in protection with
advanced sensors for every room window
and door hd security camera for inside
and outside your home smarter ways to
detect motion that only alert
that only alert you when a threat is
real and even hazard sensors that
instantly detect fires floods and other
threats to your home our monitoring
experts use proprietary advanced
response technology to visually confirm
when a break-in is real so you can get
the highest priority dispatched
police dispatch customize the perfect
system for your home in just a few
minutes at simply safe.com go today and
claim a free indoor security camera plus
20 percent off with interactive
monitoring go to simplysafe.com
s-i-m-p-l-i-s-a-f-e
dot com slash bur there's no safe like
simply
safe and isn't that what we all want to
be
um
all right well i'm still waiting for the
read so i'm gonna hit pause here uh i
won't affect your life i'll come back in
like two seconds all righty
so just hang in there all right and
don't go to the nflreference.com and
look up sam dalton thank you
all right and i am back
still don't have what i need i had what
i needed and then i looked at it and
then somehow i just i don't know
magically deleted it so i'm still
waiting for the
letters from you guys ladies and
gentlemen to listen to the podcast
evidently the volume's been too low i
just found that out so i brought it up a
little bit i apologize
um also people have been asking people
have been asking people are talking
about bill where's can i buy any of the
fenway park merch
um
that will be available this week the
store will go live we're working on
wednesday
uh follow me on the socials
i'll uh i'll post it on instagram and uh
twitter before
you know like the day before is i'll
give you plenty of time oh and the
content is here and before i get into
the content
um
you know they always all those golfers
always talk about how golf's the most
difficult game like hey man you're just
playing against yourself
it's so [ __ ] hard everybody has to
shut up when you hit the ball and all of
that
um here's another sport that you have to
shut up when they hit the ball which i
actually think is more difficult
is i think tennis
i think i could debate with somebody
i think i could present a solid argument
how it is a battle against yourself and
you have to hit a ball that's going
upwards of 130 miles an hour with spin
on it
and
like i watched one the other day where
that dude who always wins the french
open
was uh
just got smoked
the first set
and then in the second set
he finally broke the other guy
and the other guy who was playing with
him no problem kicking his [ __ ] ass
i've seen this a zillion times a zillion
times it's like
you know you know like in golf when you
hit a bad shot and then your whole
[ __ ] day falls apart
in tennis when you're playing somebody
that is ranked higher than you are
where you have to go to psychologically
to be like i can play with this [ __ ]
person and then you start kicking their
ass and you almost don't believe it and
then all of a sudden once they break you
and then the crowd gets behind the other
person because they know that person
you know and all the [ __ ] in the crowd
want to [ __ ] him afterwards and get some
of his [ __ ] i want a major tennis
money they start getting behind him how
deep you have to go and that is all on
you psychologically just like uh
just like in golf where like say if
you're playing baseball and you get the
yips somebody hits the ball to you and
you [ __ ] throw it into the stands
you know you still have like the next
guy gets up what are the odds he's gonna
hit it to you
you can still get out of that [ __ ]
inning you could go the rest of the game
and they never hit it to you
and you're sitting there
in your head freaking the [ __ ] out but
nothing ever comes of it because the
ball never goes to you
tennis isn't like that it comes after
second you hit it it comes right back to
you unless the other person [ __ ] up
i think it's a harder game personally
more athletic game all of that type of
[ __ ] i just don't the reason why people
don't understand it is because if you
walk into a
doctor's office and they see you have
high cholesterol high blood pressure and
that type of [ __ ] and they want you to
walk more they don't say take up tennis
they tell everybody out there to take up
golf why do they do that because it
involves walking and minimal athletic
ability to play the sport i would say
out of all the [ __ ] sports
that could you could just actually go
out there
i'm not saying you won't be all over the
course but people i just pick it up pick
it up and they can just you can just
play at the pace that everybody plays as
long as you bring enough [ __ ] golf
balls with you there's no other sport
like that so
um
you know part of this might be because
i'm so fair-skinneded that uh
that you know i can't play the game you
know prior to 7 p.m at night
uh 8 p.m on the west coast all right uh
here's some letters
not letters nobody has letters anymore
in email
um all right here's some emails uh
sherbert
which i learned is shorbert i don't even
know how to say it i don't know how to
[ __ ] say it anymore i don't care
because i don't order it
bootleg ice cream
uh bill i read some comments on the
youtube post of the podcast and asked
from
friends asked some friends at work we
all thought it was sherbert
anyone who didn't either manufactured
this stuff or had a relative that
invented it all right
he said that invented had a relative oh
a relative invented i was gonna say
you're as dumb as me and actually i'm
dumb because i didn't read it right
i have to go again who is using google
chrome we would like to know
[ __ ] business is it of yours um as i
answer the question
once again if you missed it last week
how
to
pronounce
i don't know how to spell it
it's h-s-h-o-b-e-r-t
how to pronounce
showbert
okay here we go here we go
where is it
shovers
shovers it's not shobbert [ __ ] you i i
refuse i i i don't accept that answer
shaubert
you want some ice cream or some
schaubert
shobert i think it's showbert
like show me the money
showbert all right morbidly morbidly
obese
greetings from across the pond i wanted
to contact you to thank you
uh it's because of you that has given me
the encouragement to get the help that
i've been silently screaming for
there's a bit of backstory so please
bear with me oh jesus christ and here i
am [ __ ] talking about global warming
and all that bringing you down i'm a 37
year old male who is registered as
morbidly obese
four months ago i hit rock bottom and as
i i as i weighed in at
463 pounds during a routine hospital
appointment i never felt so ashamed and
angry at myself as i did then
um well if it makes you feel any better
i just gave my old school sizes pre uh
pandemic and i had a fitting and like
not only could i not button the shirt i
couldn't even get the shirt together
there was like an inch of flesh showing
it's like i put on 20 coats of paint
uh for the last few years i've been
waiting for an operation called a sleeve
gastrectomy
it's where a large part of my stomach is
removed so it's much smaller than it was
before that means you cannot eat as much
as you could before surgery and you'll
feel full sooner but covet put the
brakes on that and the subsequent
backlog of operations caused
as a result i asked the hospital there's
anything that they could do in the
meantime they offered me a course of
daily injections to do at home and
appetite suppressant i've been on these
since the end of april and in that time
i've lost 54 pounds
that's great and it's still coming off i
now eat regular
somewhat healthy meals and go for walks
i'm actually thinking about starting the
gym exclamation point listen up he's
getting up like hulk hogan
he's got that that hand you know when he
went to drop the hand the last time and
it just stayed up there and the whole
[ __ ] place went nuts this is great
god help us all lol [ __ ] that dude
get out there this is awesome it's
because of you ranting on about the
obesity crisis in your comedy specials
and our podcast which gave me the
encouragement
to ask for the help i needed there you
know i know for a fact i would be dead
by the time i reached 40 if i didn't do
anything so thank you well good for you
sir or ma'am
that's awesome
and because you said that i'm actually
going gonna go for a walk in this
[ __ ] 100 degree [ __ ] heat
i got to do something
sitting around in this [ __ ] house
it's driving me crazy um
all right
although i do like being home
it's a struggle you know i do is i go
for the walks when uh when my son has a
nap
my wife took a great picture of us
yesterday we were both sitting on the
couch watching football i'm watching
football
on the couch with my son i mean it's
just it's just there's nothing better
than that
nothing there's no car there's no drum
kit this j this helicop there's no
nothing
there's just nothing and we're sitting
there and i didn't realize it we were
both sitting there the exact same way
and uh i had my hand
over my you know on my son i was rubbing
his head as we were just sitting there
staring at the tv watching so college
football my wife took this great picture
of us um
it's just the best
having the kids is the best you you
literally make however many you have
you're making friends
people you can hang out with
um
i actually had a great conversation with
my daughter
last night she was like watching tv and
i said hey can i ask you something and
she was like smiling because she wanted
to watch her show
i said can i ask you something she goes
what
and i go do you like me
and she immediately smiles she goes yeah
i go my good dad she goes yeah
and i go are you happy when i come home
and she goes yeah i go all right thanks
[Music]
you got to check in
you got to check in you can't be like
you know do you go like oh [ __ ] the
asshole's home
um all right medical talk
dear bill burgening vocabulary burr
i know that's said with a bunch of
sarcasm
uh
oh man i learned a new french word
piece of information
um that's what i'm trying to say uh i
usually let your discussions of medicine
fall by the wayside
well you know what i i would say that
you that's a very good instinct
if you do that uh because they rare
because they're rarely specific
well yeah i don't have a medical degree
um
but your fan mail today was too much for
me to be able to ignore
[Music]
oh wait a minute are you suggesting that
my ignorance
it's so ignorant that you're not you
know but it's not specific so you don't
feel it's doing any harm but evidently
you know it's like some athletic person
i took enough half court shots and one
went in
and then somebody responded and you
realized that there was a leak in the
dam and now you're gonna now you're
gonna
with your bigger brain you're gonna seal
it i hope
anyway for context i'm a general surge
i'm a general surgery resident at a
large academic institution in the
midwest
wow a lot of big words in that sentence
all right so you're uh you're a a
surgery apprentice
in a big hospital in nebraska why
couldn't you just say that
um first you're a backup quarterback in
a hospital in nebraska you can't say
that you got to see i'm a general
surgery resident and a large academic
institution in the midwest
um okay first there is definitely a lot
of doctor there's definitely a lot of
doctors can do for obese patients
although there is medication oh jesus
someone just wrote about injections and
this may help some patients what we are
finding is the
neuroformal changes that occur in
obesity obesity are overwhelming in many
ways which explains the trouble people
have losing weight on their own
second you mentioned lap band surgery
most major centers that treat obesity
and offer weight loss surgeries don't
perform this procedure anymore because
the bands
cause trouble like eroding into the
stomach
and he writes gross oh gross like i say
i was supposed to do mother billbury
like eroding into the stomach
gross
sorry sir uh we or ma'am we now do
various or they
we now do various other procedures
sleeve
gastrectomy
rule any roux
uh e bypass is that some french
procedure r o u x dash e n
capital y
uh do dead nose switch to name a few
that alter the hormonal system in
addition to offering a restrictive
component which means
you make the stomach smallest that you
feel full sooner in regards to cancer
detection
what was written from the another
listener isn't wrong but it's
horrifyingly incomplete all right this
had to do with sugars
and i don't remember what i read
i'm gonna go reagan here and say i don't
i don't recall
um
first off what is being described is
called
a pet p-e-t
position emission tomography
uh ct scan it had something to do with
them shooting sugar into your body and
the sugar goes to the cancer
meaning you should stay away from sugar
because sugar causes cancer that was the
lunch pail louie
sort of response that um
that i had on this [ __ ] from from a
listener who also wasn't a doctor or a
resident at a academic institution in a
midwestern location
um which can be id okay which can be
used to identify certain types of cancer
it's true that a radio
labeled tracer is tagged to a sugar
moiety
which is taken up by cancer cells
however the truth is that every cell in
your body uses sugar as its fuel
all food you eat is ultimately processed
down to sugar in fact when looking at
these scans there is an orange haze
produced as a result
what happens in cancer is that the cells
are rapidly growing and thus need more
fuel so they take up tons of this sugar
and thus look very bright on the scan
oh but most can ah
but most cancers aren't detected this
way breast cancer is identified on
ultrasound or x-ray
mammography colon cancer is identified
with the colonoscopy hey been there
twice
nothing identified but they definitely
looked around
i hope you've uh at least
one given i
can see your scrotum peeking out from
your
panelic
uh you get the point yeah i think you're
trying to say i'm old yes i've i've had
two
it's my voice i've had two
uh anyway
parentheses s anyway your comedy is
excellent and the podcasts get me
through so many chores around the house
without wanting to die inside i love
that you're constantly working on
yourself and your anger and i am working
on mine too for our first child a girl
oh congratulations who will be here
before i know it
uh deep dish sucks and go [ __ ] yourself
um
dude you're having a girl that's gonna
be the greatest thing for you and your
anger
because now you know you're probably i
think if you're an angry person you were
treated like [ __ ] growing up so you have
some sort of self-loathing so even if
you want to do it for yourself your
self-loathing kind of gets in the way of
it
um when you have a daughter forget about
it it's over
now you had now you have something
undeniable that you have to do it for
that's why i was asking my daughter
those questions
you know are you happy when i come home
and everything by the way she gave me a
huge hug after she said yes
um you know what's cool now she's now in
an age i don't read her books anymore
because she can start she can read now
is uh
she said last night she said dad i want
you to put to i want you to put me to
bed
and and then she said something like lie
down and talk to me and ask me the
questions you do so what i do is at
night i just lay down
next to her hopefully i don't i don't
fall asleep
her bed is comfortable so i just lay
down
and uh i feel like that's a good time to
like
check in on her see how she's doing see
how this it's going at school
um
and that type of stuff and uh
i'm telling you uh the ride that you're
signing up for is gonna be great and as
much as what you're doing with your
career is fantastic you make sure you
you have enough time for your kids
because that's what it's all about
um i know everybody knows that you still
have to say it all right shitty
neighbors shitty
neighbors oh jesus hey billy big screen
i'm reaching out to you as someone who
has a bit of a neighbor problem and have
a landlord problem so a young couple
moved into the apartment complex
let me read that again i'm reaching out
to you as someone who's had a bit of a
neighbor problem and a landlord problem
oh brother
your landlord's not helping you with
your neighbor or they're both [ __ ]
in their own worlds
oh boy here we go so a young couple
moved into the apartment complex that my
wife and i have
lived in lived at for six years and they
have a bit of a shitbox car
collecting problem our lot has enough
spots for two cars per room eight rooms
in the complex so that means there's 16
spots don't worry bill i'm coming to you
for advice the least i can do is not
make you do math
it's kind of scary how well you guys
know me at this point um anyways
it even it even says in the least that
you can only have two but the property
has undergone new management and the
newbies aren't nearly as hands-on with
the towing cars
for being ran run down pieces of [ __ ]
uh they had three and one of them was
broken down for three months before i
put a note
on there asking if they can move it or
fix it to which they replied by putting
three sheets of paper with red writing
on them on the inside of their
windshield
they read we live here the car runs mind
your own business
uh yes
yeah the ignorant
part of being ignorant is you have no
empathy which leads to
anywhere from being an [ __ ] to
joining a hate group
uh now i have walked past this car with
these sheets of paper on the windshield
for over two months and even asked the
maintenance guy to help me out citing
the lease he basically told me that
because of the toothless nature of the
owners his hands are tied now as i'm
writing to you i found out this evening
that these people went out and got a
nice car and parked it in the lot also
i thought of a lot of things including
putting painters tape on the hood
in the shape of a dick with a note on it
that says next time it'll be spray paint
move the [ __ ] car oh god
oh god now you live in that world uh but
i just can't do it yeah don't do it do i
find my zen and just deal with walking
past all these [ __ ] cars every
morning with my tail between my legs or
do i confront these people and hope for
results
i'm not a confrontational person yeah
that's why you were gonna like [ __ ] with
their car
that's what a non-confrontational person
does dude if you're not gonna go over
there and just beat the [ __ ] out which
you shouldn't do because you're either
gonna lose or you're gonna get sued
um or you could lose and get sued
there's no winning
if you're a fully functioning adult like
and you actually have done something
with your life yeah you you like
fighting is not an option past like high
school
uh i'm not a confrontational person
unless you have to okay but due to some
events that have happened in my life
over the past year i'm worried that i'll
start to see red if i they don't agree
with my request
and say some stuff that i can't take
back and will make seeing them in the
future a bit awkward thanks for the help
bill and good job in the movie i can't
wait to see it um
the way i see it you got you got three
options here
you just deal with it
you move or save up money and buy a
house
those are your options but
if the landlord isn't going to do
anything
um
i can tell you this when you move out
and the next people look at your place
and they see 20 junkers or whatever
sitting out there that's gonna [ __ ] with
their world
um i guess you could also lawyer up and
deal with that and just say it says here
in the lease i have to deal with this as
long as the cars aren't in your way
um
you know there's another thing you could
actually talk to him just say listen i'm
sorry i was in a bad mood i actually
liked the car and just talked to him
about cars and [ __ ] like that and maybe
you can just make friends with the
person
but uh or you can use it as motivation
to get the [ __ ] out of there and get you
know
get something else going
where people like that aren't in your
life but then what happens is you end up
buying a house
if you buy a house what i would suggest
is uh do a number of drive-bys
like if you look at it during the week
or on a weekend sometimes like they
strategically
show the house when whatever loud
annoying thing that might be happening
isn't happening
in like the neighborhood or whatever and
um
you know i mean i would be as bold i
mean i wouldn't be as bold i wish i was
to knock on the door of a neighbor and
just be like hey how do you like the
neighborhood is there anybody here
that's just amazing person on the other
side a major pain in the ass
blah blah blah blah no fault you know
you knock on the door the pain in the
ass
um yeah i'm sorry you're going through
that dude that's the [ __ ] worst but
um
i guess there's another thing if the car
runs you could steal it
[Music]
but everybody has cameras now that's
another reason
um
yeah don't get involved like
revenge is a uh that's one of the
darkest of all human emotions and uh
that's just not
even when somebody deserves it i just
avoid it and just
i avoid it i just like all right
whatever i'm just going to keep living
my life keep being successful at what i
want to do
whatever the [ __ ] that is and i'll just
i'll leave it all you know i looked at
those goddamn vista light drums and now
ludwig is always popping up and they
really have beautiful drums
and i wish they would stop it because
i'm going to buy a kit if they don't
stop
the exact thing that they want i mean
look at this one what the [ __ ] is that
they got a green vest you can't buy the
amber vista light i don't like how the
amber one is the only every one of the
one has like a 22 the amber one is 26
where the [ __ ] are the 24s you [ __ ]
um all right now where do we go here
talk about the bass drums if you're
wondering uh shitty neighbors
i work at fenway and need your opinion
all right i hope you're doing well i've
been listening
since 2016 but this is my first time
writing in i was at your show at fenway
and was very happy to be part of the
entire experience i actually worked
security at family but took the night
off to see the show patting myself on
the back like a hero here
i've been working on seven years
on the side i've been working for seven
years on the side i'm a full-time
student four-year underground one gap
two years law school look at you
crushing it
and i'm stationed in the area behind
home plate when i'm working jesus christ
dude why don't you just name your name
here
foul balls often end up stuck in the net
above the crowd behind home plate and
remain there until after the game when a
guy retrieves retrieves them with the
ladder after the game ends fam will
often throw objects up at the net to
knock them onto the field and then
asking us
to hand it to them we tell them not to
do this because it is a safety hazard to
those around them and as a result
we say that even if they are successful
in knocking it down we won't give it to
them yeah because you can't encourage
that i also try to warn them
of this before knocking anything down
but they don't always hear me
as you may predict even if they do hear
it people often ignore that message one
night following a game after telling
people not
knock the ball down from the net a man
about 45 years old proceeds to knock the
ball
and ask me to hand it to him given that
he blatantly ignore the instructions
i gave i pick it up and walk away which
is something we often have to do i find
a little kid and give the ball rather
than the 45 year old man i then move
from the spot on the field to walking in
the stand which are mostly empty at this
point and
clearing out stragglers as i'm walking a
lady from behind says and i quote
that was a real [ __ ] thing you did
and i'm gonna post it on social media
i immediately thought of you and
couldn't help but laugh later on what do
you think bill is this policy ridiculous
no because what would happen is that 45
year old guy is going to throw something
up there it's gonna come down on
somebody's head and either hurt him or
hit somebody who's sue happy and then
the red sox are gonna get sued not the
person that threw it
um anyway
i think you did the right thing p.s i
heard you talking about pizza places in
massachusetts
i grew up in walpole and my friends and
i always loved going to the pleasant
cafe in roslindale
it's not an individual mini bar pizza
it's regular size but it's absolutely
delicious another great spot for those
mini individual bar pizzas is called
crisp
in the wall in walpole mass it's a newer
place but it's ridiculously good uh my
friends and i have debates about whether
it's better than town spa thanks for all
the laughs and keep up the great work
sincerely larry oh my god
i'm gonna put together a coffee table
book
of these [ __ ] uh bar pizza places
no i'm not gonna do that because then
that would ruin it
everybody would go to the same [ __ ]
ones all right but i'm adding those to
my list thank you so much for that
information all right guys thank you so
much for listening
um
i think that's it go [ __ ] yourselves and
i'll check in on you on thursday and uh
i'm gonna sit in the air conditioning
hoping this global warming thing is just
a hoax and i'm gonna watch uh
my tampa bay devil race against the
yankees see what happens praying that uh
aaron judd hits a home run i'm still
rooting for that but as a red sox fan i
i am uh
i don't know i find myself watching a
lot of yankee baseball lately
sorry all right bye
you